Woke Up This Moment
of yourself
we're here
working on John Wick chapter four And So
It Begins
swag cars and weapons
and Jiu-Jitsu but with chapter four
we took it to another level
thank you
[Music]
Ryan is out
John Wood movies they're known for Keanu
Reeves doing the stunts it's been about
12 weeks of true it's new levels of
action you know let's have Moon sharks
which was challenging
Keanu attitude then the talent whether
it's handling a gun how it reloads it's
compelling to see him do it
you armed
John Wick action asks just a little bit
more and you see the effort and the
commitment from your team Ian McShane is
back with Lawrence Fishburne and Lance
Reddick and then we have Donnie Yen
Bill Skarsgard hiroyuki sonoda Clancy
Brown Shamir Anderson
incredible Natalia antenna Scott Adkins
fight Carolina Reeves
and also we have Renault
they make it look easy but it's not
for chapter four we wanted to bring the
muscle cars back we really wanted to do
something different we're gonna have the
sequence
around the Arc de triangle
we tore all the doors off and lost the
windshield you can do a reverse 180 and
you gotta shoot a gun and you gotta
reload he actually started getting too
good in the car
we're smashing people hitting people
it's just amazed we've shot some stuff
that pushes John Wick to the Limit have
we gone too far